bonjour merci d'être avec moi en direct
sur rt france alors la hongrie et la
pologne qui mettent leur veto est ce que
ça vous surprend
ça me surprend pas il faut comprendre ce
qui s'est passé et notamment mois de
juillet au mois de juillet les pays
européens se sont mis d'accord sur le
principe d'une aide massive de 720
milliards d'euros c'est considérable
mais une aile qui est quand même lié au
respect de l'état de droit au respect
des valeurs de l'union européenne
mais ce vote a eu lieu à la majorité
qualifiée et non pas l'ami à l'unanimité
comme c'est le cas actuellement
ce qui veut dire que la pologne et la
hongrie ont été à ce moment-là très
fâché parce qu'elle n'était pas d'accord
du tout avec ce lien possible entre
l'octroi de cette aide et le respect de
l'état de droit
la question c'est compliqué lorsqu'il a
fallu mettre en oeuvre cette aide
massive prod2 chose
deux décisions s'avérer importante deux
décisions qui elle devait être prise à
la majorité
d'une part à dos et ce plan des 2 720
milliards d'euros au budget pluriannuel
de l'union européenne qui s'élève à 1000
milliards d'euros ce qui est
considérable mais aussi permettre à la
commission européenne de lever ces fonds
or sur ces deux sujets il fallait le
vote à l'unanimité
et c'est d'une certaine manière pour
protester contre la décision du mois de
juillet que la hongrie d'abord puisque
c'est la hongrie qui a pris l'initiative
de bloquer ce processus
puis la pologne qu'il a accepté de la
suivre ont décidé finalement de bloquer
le processus
alors est-ce qu'il s'agit d'un blocage
extrêmement définitif je ne le pense pas
on peut penser que finalement les
discussions qui sont en cours vont
essayer d'aplanir les différends
interprétation mais il est clair que la
hongrie d'abord et la pologne
pensé par ce dispositif marquer leur
mauvaise humeur mais je rappelle quand
même que la pologne c'est à peu près 20
milliards d'euros du plan de relance
qu'elle pour dont elle pourrait
bénéficier la hongrie chez 7 milliards
d'euros
donc pour ces deux pays il sera
peut-être aussi difficile
tenir une position aussi redoutable
pendant longtemps la hongrie avait parlé
à 200 taz comment appréciez-vous ses
propos tout simplement parce que la
hongrie considère qu'elle n'a pas à
relever de l'administration de bruxelles
mais elle oublie simplement que la
hongrie dès le moment où elle a adhéré à
l'union européenne
adhérer aux grands principes de l'union
européenne ce qu'on appelle vous savez
les critères de copenhague
et parmi ces principes il y à la
séparation des pouvoirs dans le cadre
d'un état de droit
or la hongrie a adopté plusieurs
dispositifs législatifs notamment en ce
qui concerne la justice qui fait que la
justice n'est plus tout à fait
indépendante du législatif et du et du
de l'exécutif
même chose en pologne où il y a le
problème de la liberté de la presse le
problème de leur espèce des minorités
tous ces problèmes qui sont des entraves
à l'état de droit
vu sur le plan européen sont considérés
effectivement comme absolument
nécessaire pour pouvoir continuer à
travailler ensemble
donc est ce que on est dans une
situation de blocage pas tout à fait
parce que puisqu'au mois de juillet on a
accepté ils ont accepté pologne et
pologne hongrie de respecter une
certaine manière des valeurs de l'union
européenne alors je sais bien des
valeurs c'est quelque chose de
relativement flou qui n'est peut-être
pas aussi décisif que l'état de droit au
sens strict du terme
donc on peut considérer que s'il y a des
négociations qui vont s'engager et se
sont engagés et en particulièrement
aujourd'hui on peut arriver à une foule
un accord moyennant des formulations qui
choix acceptable au bras pour ces deux
pays
merci d'avoir été avec nous sur arte
france françois poule et mathis rappelle
que vous êtes journaliste spécialiste
des institutions européennes